welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast to begin
today's episode we've got some feats of
strength and we discussed two brand-new
articles that have recently gone up on
the stronger by science website one
article discusses everything lifters
would want to know about antioxidants
and the other discusses which factors
influence injury risk and power lifters
after that we discuss some research
about muscle protein synthesis and links
between artificial sweeteners and stroke
risk followed by some Q&A questions in
today's episode we also debut a brand
new segment called on the rise in which
we showcase up-and-coming creators of
fitness content that are worth a follow
finally to close out the show Greg
shares some cooking related information
then I totally upstage and outshine him
with my spicy chicken recipe as always
thank you for listening and enjoy the
show welcome back to the stronger by
science podcast this is your host Eric
Trexler and today I have a special guest
temporary host named Greg Nickels Greg
how you doing today I'm doing well
thanks for the invite I'm I am tickled
and delighted to join you today awesome
just stick to the script you be natural
and everything should be fine
so this episode's gonna air two days
before leap day and I know many of you
program you're training two three four
years in advance if you didn't account
for this extra day in the calendar year
that means trouble but fortunately Greg
you mentioned something about a
quarterly programming thing coming up
that might be of interest to our
listeners yes so after the leap day
completely throws off your program on
March 1st you can get back on the wagon
so a subreddit that I frequent our
weight room does what they call program
parties every so often I can't remember
if they're quarterly or by yearly it's
one of the two but anyway there is a new
one kicking off March 1st and the
program that was selected is average to
savage 2.0 so if you are interested in
running that program it's it's been in
beta for about a year
I was done it was done collecting all of
the feedback I needed maybe like six
months ago
and I've just been lazy about finishing
it up but it will be finalized by March
first so if you would like to do that
with a bunch of like-minded folks who
are interested in strength consider
joining the our weight room program
party one quick clarification before we
move on that start date of March 1st for
the reddit weight room program party
that is a hard cutoff so I'm gonna put a
link in the the description or the
episode notes here if you've signed up
for the program party using that link by
March 1st you'll you'll automatically be
added to the average to Sanford
subreddit and you'll get access to the
program otherwise you'll have to wait
until that program goes on sale on our
website stronger by science calm which
should be relatively soon I tell you
what we've got is it one feat of
strength or two here we got two coming
up well it's two but I also have another
thing I'd like to start the show with ok
it is today I believe everybody's
favorite holiday so we're recording this
on Oh No yeah yeah ok I'm looking at the
right day we're recording this on
February 21st and today is as we all
know national sticky bun day so if you
forgot to celebrate on the 21st you're
listening to this when it came out go
out and get a sticky bun they're nice
you know as a true patriot I usually
turn presidents day into a week-long
thing so I don't know if I can fit two
holidays into the mix but but for those
who observe you know sticky bun day
sounds great what are some of your
favorite Presidents Day traditions the
family gets around we read the
Constitution take turns going through it
there's all sorts of stuff it's good
what's your favorite amendment oh I
couldn't even pick there's so many
honestly I'm not a fan of the amendments
I think they got it right the first time
and
honestly supporting any of the
amendments is just trampling on the
immortal wisdom of the framers okay well
that's sarcastic for sure let's go ahead
and move on I don't I don't want the
constitutionalist to come after
okay so constitutional scholars that was
just a joke let's get to the feats of
strength all right so we just have to
this time around if you'll remember last
episode there were approximately a
shit-ton but I guess people have just
decided to not be as strong for the past
couple of weeks but the two that we have
are super super cool and very impressive
which will hopefully make up for it
somewhat so I saw some people sharing a
video around of a fairly small woman
deadlifting big weights and I saw it and
said wow she's quite strong and then I
looked into who it was and it became
just batshit crazy very quickly allow me
to explain so the lifters name is
Samantha Eugenie she dead lifted to 10
at 63 or in freedom units for 63 at 139
lifts looked very good it was very
smooth she wasn't wearing straps so you
know it looked to be a dead lift up to
competition standard it was a gym lift
and that in and of itself is a very very
impressive deadlift in that weight class
I think it's I think it would be top 10
or like borderline top 10 the world
record in that weight class is 262 or
498 pounds by Samantha Calhoun so you
know it's it's like fairly close to the
world record I was like oh that's pretty
strong and then I started reading
comments of who were like oh I can't
believe she's only 17 and that's when I
said what the [ __ ] going on right now
so potential blind spot for me I don't
follow
teenage powerlifting closely at all and
I especially don't really follow female
teenage powerlifting at all that
probably may
me a bad person so I had to go on open
powerlifting in check like just how
bonkers is that deadlift for a 17 year
old girl and it turns out it's pretty
[ __ ] bonkers she already has
Samantha Jeannie already has the world
record in the 16 and 17-year old age
division at her last meet she pulled 190
kilos which is 418 pounds and the next
closest person to her in that age and
weight division pulls 173 or 381 and so
like I'm not trying to poopoo that at
all
yeah a 17 year old regardless of size
and sex pulling close to four plates is
impressive you know a hundred and forty
pound girl pulling close to four plates
is impressive but Samantha Eugenie
pulling you know for 63 that's bonkers
so we very well may have the next the
next deadlift prodigy on our hands which
is pretty cool so props to her super
super impressive the second one also a
young female lifter but this one is like
objectively more bonkers so it's someone
we've talked about on the show before
mahalia reeves she benched 375 at in the
super heavyweight division
I think her prior record was either 365
or 370 but yeah so she went 375 and the
reason that's bonkers is that moves her
into sixth place all time for all-female
ventures including untested which is
wild so I mean like steroids obviously
help people of both sexes get strong but
seem to have a proportionally larger
effect for for females than males but so
you know comfortably in the top ten all
time there and it is the number two
tested
female bench of all-time behind only
Roberta Collins who did I think 390 or
391 all the way back in 2003 so you know
it's the biggest number any any woman is
hit in the past 18 years she's still
improving
she's only 16 years old so I mean it's
hard for me to put into words how
ludicrously impressive that is you know
when you think sports where athletes are
in the top 2 2 in the world ever at 16
years old
the list is essentially like gymnastics
and that's it
that doesn't generally apply to
powerlifting and generally if it does
apply to powerlifting that's gonna be in
some of the lighter weight classes like
generally heavy weights peak a little
bit later in their careers so number 2
tested bench all-time in the super
heavyweight division at 16 years old and
like it's 375 like regardless of any of
that like that's a that's not a bad
bench for anyone and the fact that it's
a 16 year old girl [ __ ] crazy
so anyway super super impressive yeah
that's crazy alright so we've talked in
the past we used to do the podcast every
week we switch to every other week we
said we were gonna write more we've got
two new articles up on the website that
have gone up in the last couple weeks in
the past we've used the podcast to kind
of talk about some of the articles that
have gone up after we have a chance to
get some feedback on them see how people
react to them so I'm gonna talk a little
bit about the article I recently posted
on the site about antioxidants and
you're gonna talk about our recent
article on injury rates in lifters so
antioxidants if you're a longtime
listener of the podcast we've talked
about them before and I kept basically
saying I'm gonna reserve my opinion
until after I've had a chance to really
dig through the literature
and finish my article so now is the time
and the reason that this really came up
the reason we wanted to put out some
content about antioxidants is it's
really really commonly accepted in the
lifting world that antioxidant
supplements will blunt hypertrophy and
you hear people say it all the time and
I mean we've said it you know because
there is some degree of evidence
supporting that but what we wanted to do
is basically evaluate that literature
closely and say how much of how big of a
deal is it to have high dose
antioxidants when it comes to strength
adaptations or more specifically
hypertrophy adaptations to resistance
training
now with the antioxidant literature I
feel like in the fitness world you see
antioxidants get talked about a lot but
usually very very vaguely and I couldn't
find a lot of good accessible articles
that really just kind of gave a baseline
rundown of what people need to know
about antioxidant so my hope for this
article is whether or not you're
interested in the super applied stuff
about hypertrophy at the very least the
beginning half of the article is just
like let's figure out what the
terminology is because a lot of times
people use these terms vaguely or
interchangeably when they probably
shouldn't be using them that way so the
first thing to get out of the way with
antioxidants getting through this
literature's messy there's a lot of
stuff going on you know so for example
flavonoids there are over 4,000 known
distinct types of flavonoids and that's
just one class of polyphenols and
polyphenols are just one class of non
enzymatic antioxidants so when you start
with the vague term antioxidant you
start breaking it into subgroups and
subgroups of those subgroups and so on
down the line we're talking about
thousands and thousands of distinct
compounds so that's one of the things
that's frustrating when you try to dive
into this literature is I mean what do
you even search for do you search for
vitamin C or polyphenols or a specific
polyphenol
really have to cast a broad net when you
try to summarize this stuff so what I
don't want to do is essentially read the
article like paraphrase it section by
section here because that's not
particularly fascinating to listen to I
do encourage you to check out the
article stronger by science comm slash
antioxidants but just to give you an
idea of what you're getting into if you
were to go to that article the first
half just clears up a bunch of
terminology about antioxidants that you
may have heard before but like I said a
lot of times people kind of tiptoe
around the language and use it very
vaguely cuz you have to really get into
the details if you're trying to
elucidate exactly what these terms mean
and how they relate to each other so I
talked a little bit about what an
antioxidant is what it does talked a
little bit about why it's important to
manage oxidative stress so you know we
create when we when we begin exercise
for example we start to generate
reactive species which is kind of an
umbrella term that refers to free
radicals reactive oxygen species
reactive nitrogen species so in the
article I just say let's group those
together we're gonna call them reactive
species and when we engage in exercise
oxidative stress and the production of
these different reactive species does go
up and if we were to completely blunt
the production of reactive species
muscle contractility would be reduced so
we want there to be some kind of
increase in reactive species production
when we exercise but too much production
of ract reactive species is equally
problematic so elevated levels of
reactive species can damage all sorts of
proteins throughout the body and are
also associated with fatigue during
exercise so we want to manage reactive
species we want there to be sufficient
production but not excessive production
and where antioxidants come into play is
they they mitigate some of the effects
of reactive species production they can
attenuate their production they can
scavenge them after they're produced so
that or they can affect enzymes that
then
work to eventually scavenge them through
endogenous processes so can I drop a
very random fun fact in here right now
absolutely so you mentioned that high
levels of reactive species production
can damaged proteins damaged DNA well I
don't think you mentioned DNA but that's
a nice trick you know and just you know
just generally negatively impact various
cell structures so this is related as
you'll see in a second but that
partially explains why birds live so
long so here's the fun fact if you plot
metabolic rate versus lifespan on a
log-log graph you can just draw a
straight line through it like it's a
pretty well described 3/4 power
exponential relationship and it is it
seems to have a fair amount to do with
mitochondrial capacity and thus like
oxidative stress resulting from free
radical production and so essentially
like when things have faster metabolisms
like they're they're producing more
reactive species they accumulate more
cell damage they age faster they die
faster there's more to it than that but
that seems to be like one of the major
driving factors cool thing about birds
is they can fly a lot of people don't
know that but that is a defining
characteristic of birds and fun fact
about flight is it is unbelievably
energy intensive like it takes I don't
know this is probably wrong but it's
probably in about the right ballpark it
takes like 20 times more energy to fly
than it does to run like it's a huge
huge difference and so as we all know
mitochondria are the powerhouse of the
cell and for a bird to be able to fly it
needs it just an absolutely enormous
amount of mitochondria
in all of the muscles that relate to
flight and so because of that they have
an insanely high oxidative capacity and
also because of that they have
substantially lower free radical
production than other animals of similar
size with similar metabolic rates and so
like for example humans are I think the
biggest outlier when it comes to life
span like most things that are
approximately our size live like em
maybe like 20-30 years give or take but
you know that's like pretty long-lived
for an animal like elephants live longer
some reptiles live super long but
basically like once you start getting
down into like the 20-30 pound range you
know then you're talking about dogs and
stuff lives 10-15 years maybe 20 if
you're super lucky but like kind of in
the 10 to 15 year range whereas if you
have a bird that size it might be living
30 40 50 even 60 years some albatrosses
have been known to live for like 70 80
years plus and even like smaller birds
which are like comparable in size to
mice which don't live long at all can
live you know 10 20 years and so one of
the reasons for that is they have so
many mitochondria that just like
day-to-day energy production produces
far fewer free radicals and so they age
at a much much slower rate and that is
not the only reason but probably the
biggest reason why birds are like as an
entire class of creatures way way longer
lived than one would anticipate them to
be given their size and metabolic rate
well there you go fun fact about birds
so getting back to antioxidant
supplementation I just think that's
really cool no it is cool it's very cool
well isn't that from that book yeah so
I've recommended this book probably four
times on the podcast already
but power sex suicide mitochondria and
the meaning of life it's an entire book
about mitochondria and I know you're
thinking God that sounds so cool I
promise you it's at least twice as cool
as you think it is it's by Nick Lane and
I would strongly strongly recommend it I
still need to get around to reading that
I will admit it's really good so in this
article like I mentioned the the
management of total oxidative stress you
know the production of reactive species
and then the neutralization of reactive
species it's really important for us to
keep those things regulated within a
certain workable range now we have
endogenous systems that do that but
obviously it's also impacted by our
dietary intake of antioxidants and so
that that's kind of what the first half
of the article is basically saying what
a reactive species how do they relate to
our performance and health and how did
dietary antioxidants fit into that
picture so if you ever hear somebody
saying a bunch of stuff about
antioxidants that seems weird just go to
this article read the first half see if
it fits in if it kind of fits into that
narrative if not it's possible that
they're a little bit off base or might
have some information a little bit mixed
up there after that I get into some of
the more practical aspects of
antioxidant intake and supplementation I
look at some of the effects on blood
flow acute performance which mostly
currently the literature looks at
endurance type outcomes for exercise I
look a little bit at the effects on
recovery obviously I don't want to go
and point-by-point recap everything in
the article but the general takeaways
are that there is some good evidence to
suggest that various antioxidant
supplements can promote blood flow
during exercise things like grape juice
pomegranate extract cocoa
supplementation those things that there
is some evidence suggesting that they do
promote blood flow during exercise which
could be a beneficial thing for
performance in theoretically recovery as
well then I talked a little bit about
acute performance like I said the
performance
it's fine like I said most of its
looking at endurance type activities
there is some good evidence for things
like beetroot juice which have a lot of
antioxidants grape extract but really
the beetroot juice literature it's a
little bit it's hard to lump it in as an
antioxidant supplement because it's
really a nitrate supplement that happens
to have antioxidants so when you look at
the effects on blood flow those are
those make a lot of sense because
antioxidants reduce the conversion of
nitric oxide to peroxy nitrite and
essentially extend or increase the
bioavailability of nitric oxide which
promotes blood flow so with the blood
flow those are very intuitive results
that we see a modest but noticeable
enhancement of exercise blood flow the
acute performance data essentially like
I said when we have have thousands and
thousands of different compounds it's
hard to put a singular summary statement
on the literature but generally speaking
it's neutral to slightly positive for
many of the compounds there are
certainly several for which there are
really no tangible benefits but there
are a few different antioxidant based
supplements that have been shown to
enhance various types of performance I
wouldn't hang my hat on antioxidants as
in acute performance boosting supplement
strategy but there might be something
there for some of these supplements and
if you want to look into some of the
details about which ones seem to work
which ones don't like I said you can
always head over to the article and
check it out
I look looked at a little bit of the
recovery literature there are some
studies with things like pomegranate
juice and watermelon juice showing
enhanced recovery from intense or
exhaustive exercise same thing with tart
cherry juice so that evidence looks a
little bit better than the acute
performance data there are things
looking at various metrics related to
oxidative stress inflammation even just
the recovery of force production and
soreness after exercise where some of
those more plant-based antioxidant
juices and extracts do seem to have some
positive effects but the thing we really
wanted to talk about in this particular
article was training adaptation
and like I said that the thing that
really got this got us going on this
topic was a recent meta-analysis that
was looking at the effects of vitamin C
and E supplementation on strength and
hypertrophy outcomes in response to
training now one of the reasons people
are really open to this idea that
antioxidant supplements blunt
hypertrophy there are multiple studies
showing that high dose antioxidant
supplementation reduces the activity of
certain anabolic signaling pathways
related to hypertrophy so it's a very
intuitive extension logically that if
you're reducing the activity of these
hypertrophy promoting pathways you're
probably going to be blunting
hypertrophy but we really shouldn't
always assume that to be the case and so
like for example if you look at the
endurance training literature with
antioxidants we see several studies
showing that antioxidant supplementation
interferes with signaling pathways
related to mitochondrial biogenesis
which is a big-time adaptation when it
comes to an endurance capacity in
response to training however despite
that most of the studies looking at the
effects on actual endurance capacity and
performance and endurance activities it
doesn't seem quite as bleak as the
signaling outcomes would indicate so
it's it's actually kind of a mixed bag
the signalling stuff looks really bad
for endurance adaptations but when you
actually look at vo2 max time to
exhaustion the the idea of blunted
training adaptations really isn't as
pronounced as you would expect them to
be when it comes to resistance training
stuff like I mentioned there was that
meta-analysis by Clifford and colleagues
and we'll link that in the show notes
when it comes to strength outcomes I
really didn't look into him that much
because it's hard to think of a
mechanism by which antioxidant
supplementation would blunt strength
performance
aside from by blunting hypertrophy you
would think if there's going to be some
effect on strength it's going to be
essentially by reducing hypertrophy and
having more of a long term effect and
what what they found they did do that in
their meta-analysis and
the result for high dose vitamin C and E
supplementation when it came to strength
outcomes it was a non significant
finding but if anything it was actually
a very small effect favoring the
antioxidant groups rather than the
placebo group so there's really no meat
on the bone there to really probe
further and try to figure out if if
there's some kind of link by which high
dose antioxidants would blunt strength
outcomes with the hypertrophy outcomes
the meta-analysis did find essentially
no significant effect in either
direction and what I do in the article
is I dig into a few of the key studies
to really consider there these are
studies that took direct measures of
various hypertrophy outcomes looking
either at the level of like a muscle
fiber or looking at muscle size using
MRI or ultrasound something like that
basically anything other than just a
global measure of like you know DEXA fat
free mass looking at more specific more
localized indices of hypertrophy there
were some select variables within these
studies that you know the the placebo
group outperformed the antioxidant group
in terms of the the magnitude of
hypertrophy obtained but the effects
that were noted in these studies were
pretty modest in magnitude and more
importantly quite inconsistent so my gut
reaction just based on how people talked
about this topic in the fitness industry
was that okay well you know I'm sure
there's gonna be a pretty consistent and
fairly notable blunting of hypertrophy
in response to these high dose
antioxidant interventions and in in
reality that doesn't seem to be the case
if there is an effect it seems to be
pretty inconsistent and not particularly
large in magnitude no I thought the
exact same thing I thought not
necessarily that it was a completely
close case but that like either at
minimum you know there were studies that
that mostly kind of indicated that high
dose antioxidants might have a negative
effect on hypertrophy or you know maybe
it was a case where like there's two
studies and they
both said antioxidants aren't good but
maybe we didn't have a consensus because
there wasn't that much research and
there's not a ton of research but you
know there is enough to consider at a
body of literature I'd say and I very
much felt the same way as you like it
was it was way way more inconsistent
than I believed it to be because people
do talk about it as if it's just a known
fact that high dose antioxidants blend
hypertrophy yeah and one of the
fascinating things that I found as I
continued to kind of dig into this
literature is there's a great review by
Ishmael at all and they talk about the
evidence that basically indicating that
the effects of vitamin C and E might be
distinct from the effects we see from
other kind of plant derived
phytonutrients antioxidants so when we
look at like various types of
polyphenols sources what they indicated
was you know if you give someone a
really high dose of vitamin C they're
gonna have a big increase in in you know
plasma levels of vitamin C it's a pretty
straightforward mechanism by which you
take vitamin C it goes up in the blood
it directly scavenges reactive species
and that's a pretty open-and-shut case
in terms of what's going on there and so
what they what they suggest is basically
if you're a person that doesn't have
excessive oxidative stress and excessive
levels of reactive species in your blood
you know if you're a healthy fit
individual who doesn't have some kind of
clinical outcome that increases
oxidative stress there's probably no
benefit and potentially some downsides
to really high dose vitamin C
supplementation however if you do have
some kind of clinical condition or if
you're an older person who tends to have
older people tend to have higher levels
of oxidative stress beyond a certain age
then it might actually be a beneficial
thing but what's really interesting is
that they are talking about polyphenols
specifically as one category of these
different kind of plant-based
phytonutrient antioxidants and you know
when we take polyphenols it's unlikely
that we're gonna have some huge increase
in plasma polyphenol concentrate
in response to that more likely what
what they reckon is going on is that
when you take polyphenols or some other
kind of phytonutrient antioxidant those
are probably activating nrf2
and that is having kind of secondary
antioxidant effects so you're activating
nrf2 which is then increasing the
activation of endogenous antioxidant
enzymes so it actually what they
proposed is the effects for vitamin C
and E when it comes to hypertrophy there
might be some degree of blunting it's
like I said it's not large and it's not
particularly consistent but what's
interesting is that the the evidence
pertaining to polyphenols and other
phytonutrients you really don't see any
evidence at all related to the blunting
of hypertrophy and they suspect that
there are some distinct mechanisms that
would describe why there's potentially
some divergent outcomes so if you want
to get down into the details about this
whole body of literature I do encourage
you to check out the article in terms of
the take home conclusions I do feel
pretty confident suggesting that a diet
that's rich in antioxidants from food
sources is a damn good idea I really
don't see any downside to that high-dose
antioxidant supplementation particularly
if we're talking about vitamin C and
vitamin E is generally probably not
advisable and the reason I say that is
there's a lack of meaningful benefit
when we look at the potential for
performance enhancement reduction in
soreness or recovery anything like that
very low likelihood of a meaningful
benefit and there is a small risk of
some detriment you know there it would
be incorrect to say that there's no
evidence of blunted hypertrophy in
response to high-dose vitamin C
supplementation
the big caveat there is that it is a
small effect in a pretty inconsistent
effect but when you consider the
potential pros and the potential cons I
just don't see justification for
embarking in a strategy that involves
high-dose vitamin C and E
supplementation especially for an
individual who doesn't
have unusually high oxidative stress at
baseline so you know if if you hear
people talking about how antioxidants
should be avoided for people with
hypertrophy related goals that would not
be really justified by the evidence but
you could probably say hey maybe not a
good idea to have super high doses of
vitamin C and E what's really
interesting though I get a lot of
questions about you know people saying
hey I heard antioxidants blunt
hypertrophy but what does that mean for
things like beetroot juice which
naturally have a pretty high dose of
polyphenols and other antioxidant
compounds in them and what the
literature appears to indicate for now
is that those different plant-based
sources that are kind of naturally
occurring in fruits and vegetables and
the juice is extracted from them they
don't seem to behave the same way as a
high-dose supplementation regimen with
vitamin C or E so I think if you're
getting your antioxidants from fruits
vegetables or the juice is extracted
from them or even you know powdered
extracts from them it wouldn't appear
that you have anything to worry about
there in terms of blunting hypertrophy
vitamins C and E the effects of blunting
hypertrophy are probably overstated but
they're still just really low potential
for benefit from that strategy and a
small possibility of detriment in terms
of hypertrophy so if you want to get
like I said all the details all the
references head over to that that link
stronger by science comm slash
antioxidants you can check out the full
article there may I ask your hot take on
something yes okay so in general plant
sources of antioxidants seem to be
pretty chill high-dose concentrated
vitamin C and E maybe not so much where
would something like a greens powder
fall I don't think it's quite as popular
among fitness people anymore but I know
that I mean I know that there's still a
ton of people to do this and it used to
be super super popular there was a brand
called athletic greens I think that used
to sponsor everyone in there brother
and people would say like I'll just
throw some of this and you're like pre
and post-workout shake you know it's
it's the best thing since sliced bread
where would something like that fall
because it's it's like a concentrated
thing but like theoretically it's just
ground up freeze-dried plants yeah I
mean I remember when those were huge I
one of the things that drove me nuts
about those is that people just
completely stopped eating vegetables
that's like I don't I don't think that's
what you want to do it is kind of in a
gray area what I would if I had to make
a decision based on the evidence I have
available now what I do is I would look
at it and say does this have five
hundred or a thousand milligrams of
vitamin C if that were the case I'd
probably stay away from it and just be
like it doesn't make any sense I have no
idea what the vitamin C content of those
things is yeah I don't either if it's
just giving me a super concentrated dose
of these various phytonutrients that
appear to activate nrf2 in that case I
probably would be fine with it but what
what what I would do based on what we
have available you know it'd be great to
have direct research on it obviously but
I'd say if it's giving me a like mega
dose of vitamin C I'd probably just shy
away from it if the vitamin C is similar
to just having like a big serving of
vegetables and there's just a bunch of
other phytonutrients in there then it's
probably fine cool all right now we had
another article in the last few weeks
that was about injuries so I'm gonna let
you take it away with that one we did so
this article was by Andrew Patton and
myself and to be completely transparent
the division of labor was like 92%
Andrew and like 8% me so he gets that
byline to himself but anyway this was
the culmination of I don't know like the
better part of four years of
intermittent work like very intermittent
work so back in like 2016 give
take I sent out a survey just to kind of
get get the lay of the land of like what
do power lifters look like and I mean
obviously I know kind of the basics the
basic answers to that question but you
know on a more on a broader level like
how strong are people really on average
you know disregarding my biases from
like what I've seen in this specific
gyms that I've trained in how much
experience to most power lifters tend to
have what sorts of training programs are
they running yada yada yada just
collected a bunch of data about a bunch
of different things one of the things we
asked about was injuries so we were just
surveying at one time point so it was
essentially asking about injury history
so have you ever sustained an injury
which pretty much everyone had but then
like what sites had been injured what
was the nature of those injuries etc so
I had done some stuff with that data set
Andrew who's my buddy found out that I
was sitting on that data found out that
I had injury data and said like hey do
you mind if I tear into this and we can
publish some stuff on injuries so I said
sure and so 2017 we put out an article
just looking at that cross-sectional
stuff which was kind of cool but also
wasn't super informative just because of
the you know the great drawbacks of a
single time point retrospective analysis
like that so we decided to get a better
dataset to look at injuries and
powerlifters we would run a prospective
study meaning essentially we'd recruit
people and we'd send them surveys every
single month to get an idea of did you
get hurt this month that was our outcome
of interest but then also how strong are
you are you getting stronger what does
your training look like you know how
frequently do you train what's your
training volume look like
what proportion of your training is like
really high-intensity stuff and a bunch
of other things so we ran that for a
year we collected all of the data we
previously published a couple articles
just kind of dipping our toes into the
water of you know here's what our sample
looks like here are some very very basic
results and the final article in that
series was recently published which was
you know finally doing our full data
analysis like our full model to really
get an idea of at least of the variables
we collected of the data we collected
what seems to be most predictive most
indicative of subsequent injury risk so
before I talked about this I should have
pulled up our precise definition of
injury but it was it was a pretty strict
definition of injury okay I got it so we
defined an acute injury as any bone
fracture muscle ligament or tendon tear
or any joint sprain dislocation or
separation so that was one possible
definition our second possible
definition was any injury that
necessitated a trip to a MD or physical
therapist not a chiropractor or a
massage therapist because you know
sometimes people just go and get
massages or go to the chiropractor just
because or any injury of any variety
that necessitated taking time off of
training for two weeks or greater so for
example if you kind of like I don't know
maybe like tweak a hammy a little bit
it's not anything serious you take your
next squat workout a little bit easier
and then the workout after that you're
fine you're good to go
we didn't count that as an injury
whereas if it was something more serious
and you had to take a couple weeks off
of squatting to try to work at rehabbing
it that would be counted as an injury so
it was a it was I would say a pretty
strict definition of injury that
would capture the big stuff that happens
to people but not just kind of normal
aches and pains that a lifter might
experience just in the course of normal
training so we wanted to see like of all
of the of all of the data we gathered
what seems to be the most predictive of
injury risk so we ran the data several
different ways if you want all of the
details on that you can check out the
article but at the end of the day what
seemed to be the most predictive of like
future injury risk since this was a
prospective study was having prior
physical limitations at the start of
this year of training so people who in
their first survey said like hey like
I'm not injured I'm not currently taking
time off of training but you know maybe
I have like the shoulder thing that's
bothering me a little bit or like my
hamstring feels a little janky but like
you know not enough to really make me do
anything about my training so folks like
that who were coming in with some sort
of physical limitation were
approximately three times as likely to
get injured in their subsequent year of
training as people who came into the
study without any reported prior
physical limitations so the hazard ratio
there was right around 3.0 with a 90
with a 95% confidence interval spreading
from two to four and a half so that's a
fairly wide confidence interval but even
the very bottom end of it is - meaning
you know rosiest scenario you're two
times as likely to get injured worst
case scenario closer to four and a half
times as likely to get injured so that
was very very strongly predictive of
subsequent injury risk and that was
actually the only thing in our model
that was statistically significant using
you know the the typical standard
frequentist definition of a p-value less
than or equal to point of
five so there were a couple other
variables that were either the hazard
ratio was big enough that it's possibly
meaningful even though there was a
fairly wide confidence interval or the
effect was kind of small but the p-value
was kind of low but not quite to 0.05 so
there were a couple things that kind of
fell into that you know marginally
possibly meaningful category one of them
was sex so it seemed like on average
male lifters were about one and a half
times more likely to get injured than
female lifters but we didn't have we
didn't have enough female lifters in our
sample to make that a super like robust
analysis so the the hazard ratio was 1.5
meaning 1.5 times more likely to get
injured but the confidence interval was
from point eight to two point nine so
that you know that's all the way from oh
maybe female lifters are actually 20%
more likely to get injured all the way
to male lifters are about three times as
likely to get injured so you know it
kind of seems like with a hazard ratio
of 1.5 maybe the male lifters are a
little more injury prone but we didn't
have enough statistical power and
frankly enough female subjects to
conclude that with a super high degree
of confidence and then the other thing
one of the one of the things we asked
them is like do you do any cardio or
like circuit training just in any sort
of conditioning work and if so how many
days per week do you do it
we found that days of conditioning work
seemed to have a protective effect
against injury so this is one where the
the effect was reasonably small but the
confidence interval barely contained one
so the p-value is like 0.09 which you
know isn't technically significant but
but is reasonably close and that
frequentist criteria can suck it anyways
it's dumb so the the hazard ratio there
was point nine two which essentially
means for every
one day of conditioning work people did
they were about eight percent less
likely to get injured and like I said
fairly tight confidence interval from
0.82 to 1.01 so you know seems that we
can be reasonably confident that it has
a small beneficial effect probably not a
harmful effect and all equally likely
probably not a large beneficial effect
so it's it's hard to know really where
the causation of that one goes like what
direction the causality goes if there is
a causal relationship at all you know it
could just be that folks who do a lot of
cardio or you know do not even a lot but
say like two or three days of cardio per
week aren't as like quote unquote
hardcore as folks who are like cardio is
dumb who wants to do cardio ever for any
reason and so you know maybe they just
aren't aren't as likely to push
themselves and like do stupid stuff and
get injured because of that reason so
that's one possibility
another possibility is that it is a kind
of like legitimate causal type thing
where doing some conditioning work has
some sort of direct protective effect
one possible explanation for that is we
know from research on athletes that like
non-contact muscle and ligament injuries
are a lot more common late in games than
early in games one of the reasons for
that is just as neuromuscular fatigue
sets in you start to lose some degree of
motor control and so you know some
maneuver you attempt that your nervous
system could coordinate well when you
were fresh now it doesn't coordinate
quite as well when you're a little bit
fatigued theoretically possibly the same
thing could apply to training as well so
you know if you do some cardio you're in
a little bit better shape you just get
less overall neuromuscular fatigue you
can maintain motor control a little bit
better throughout a training session
and are therefore maybe less likely to
get injured for that reason so yeah I
mean we didn't have these people all in
one place to take tissue samples and do
blood draws and investigate mechanism so
it's hard to know for sure what explains
that finding related to cardio / tential
II being protective but you know seem to
be a reasonably reliable effect within
our sample and then I think the other
interesting thing that we found was all
of the things we didn't find so we kind
of thought that maybe stronger lifters
when Kovarian for sex would be maybe
more likely to sustain injuries than
weaker lifters just because you know
you're stronger you're putting more
force through the tissues your training
and so like on a per exposure basis you
may just be more capable of overloading
those tissues and possibly causing
injuries we denta find that to be the
case
we thought maybe older lifters would be
a little bit more injury prone than
younger lifters we didn't find that to
be the case I think Andrew thought that
higher training frequencies would be
predictive of injury I kind of thought
they wouldn't because generally higher
frequency often means lower volume per
session so I I kind of thought those two
things would balance out and we didn't
find the training frequency was
predictive of injury risk we didn't find
that volume was predictive of injury
risk we didn't find that the proportion
of training with heavy loads which we
operationally defined as loads in excess
of 85% of 1rm we didn't find that that
was predictive of injury risk so the
only thing that that very much seemed
for sure predictive of subsequent injury
risk was did you have some sort of prior
physical limitation being male possibly
increases injury risk and doing some
cardio possibly slightly decreases
injury risk literally nothing else
seemed to be predictive really to any
degree whatsoever
and so yeah I thought that maybe some of
those training variables would be
predictive but they were not at all all
right now Greg I know you have a little
research review planned but before we
get into that I do want to have a little
bit of a clarification so I believe it
was our most recent episode I talked a
little bit about artificial sweeteners
and various health-related concerns that
people often voice about them and my
general assessment of the artificial
sweetener literature is that they're
pretty much pretty okay you know when
you look at the common concerns people
have there's really not a lot of
evidence to justify the generally
negative outlook that a lot of people
have so the key things that come up that
I addressed were things related to gut
health things related to cancer risk
things related to weight gain and
appetite and when you look at the
artificial sweetener literature with
those particular outcomes in mind the
literature looks pretty good they just
seem to be quite neutral when it comes
to those those things now after that I
did get a message from one of our
listeners which was always appreciated
by the way Greg and I won't get
defensive we like to get feedback and
every once in a while once every several
years we will in fact be wrong about
something and it's always important to
know that but in this case the listener
was like so you talked about these
particular outcomes but what about
stroke and dementia and I'll be honest
that was a blind spot for me I I totally
forgot that people I totally forgot that
there was some buzz last year in the
year before about whether or not
artificial artificial sweeteners might
be linked to increased risk of stroke or
dementia so I completely forgot to
address one of the notable health
concerns a lot of people have so I
looked back at some of the more recent
literature looking at the the links
between artificial sweeteners and stroke
and dementia there was a paper by
massive ar-rahmani and colleagues and
what they found this was like kind of a
big
epidemiology type paper was that higher
self-reported intake of artificially
sweetened beverages was associated with
increased risk of stroke and some other
bad stuff now one of the cool things was
that Journal it's pretty good about
publishing commentary and kind of
responses to the articles and there
there was a really excellent piece of
commentary and I'll link it in the show
notes here but basically what they found
in this study the headline looks pretty
bad you're like okay at face value a
higher risk of stroke I don't like that
but one of the people that submitted
commentary brought up a really good
point and that was that what they found
in this study was that heavy consumption
of artificially sweetened beverages was
associated with an increased risk of
stroke but only among obese individuals
when they looked at that association in
people that were either normal weight or
overweight based on BMI cut-offs that
relationship was not found and so my
takeaway from that and the takeaway from
the person who submitted that commentary
is that that's probably evidence that at
least suggests that there's some reverse
causality going on basically that in the
people who were obese who after becoming
obese said maybe I need to try some
strategies for weight reduction I'm
gonna switch over to artificially
sweetened beverages in the people who
are already obese that link was observed
in normal-weight individuals it was not
so the idea is that it's it's probably
likely that individuals became obese
again based on the BMI cut-offs and at
that point adopted the use of
artificially sweetened beverages and
that that might be one of the things
that would be contributing to that
apparent link now in the commentary one
critique I had was they said you could
interpret that a different way maybe
it's possible that the artificially
sweetened beverage consumption actually
led to weight gain and that's what was
causing the link in these obese
individuals that theoretically could be
true but when you look at the controlled
trials that actually evaluate that
particular outcome you know do we see
people gain weight
when we initiate the consumption of
artificially sweetened beverages that
concept is not supported and the the
controlled trials on that are a much
stronger much more robust source of
evidence than these you know kind of
speculating about these correlations in
observational data now that's not the
only paper making these types of links
there was a paper by pace and colleagues
and what they found in that paper was a
higher recent and higher cumulative
intake of artificially sweetened soft
drinks were associated with increased
risk of stroke and dementia as well
interestingly they found that the in the
consumption of sugar-sweetened beverages
was not associated with stroke or
dementia again this is one of the papers
where there was commentary submitted and
whenever I look at a paper I like to see
the commentary see what other people are
saying and again they kind of took the
words right out of my mouth but in this
case that there is you could make a very
strong case that again this is
confounded by reverse causation so when
they looked at this particular data
people who were consuming artificially
sweetened beverages showed a higher
prevalence of hypertension diabetes and
cardiovascular disease than people who
were regularly taking in high intakes of
sugar sweetened beverages so again we
see some clues within the data itself
indicating that this apparent link
between artificially sweetened beverages
and these deleterious outcomes the most
likely scenario is that people who were
already at increased health risks
because they had become obese they
probably switched over and began
consuming these artificially sweetened
beverages and that's why we're seeing
this linked with some of these negative
health outcomes because at face value I
can't imagine that anyone would argue
that switching from an artificially
sweetened beverage to a sugar sweetened
beverage would reduce your risk of
hypertension diabetes or cardiovascular
disease I just can't imagine somebody
seriously making that point is there a
purported mechanism by which
artificially sweetened beverages could
cause those things the only specific one
that I've seen
there are a couple that thought that
they seemed like a stretch where they're
like alright we got to make something
work here the most common one that you
see when it comes to these types of
papers is they'll say well maybe the
artificially sweetened beverages are
predisposing people to obesity and
having kind of an indirect effect there
were a couple others mentioned but but
to me they seem like a stretch to the
extent that I don't even remember them
because I saw them on the page and I
said that doesn't make any sense and I
promptly forgot them so usually what
these papers do when they linked
artificially sweetened beverages to some
kind of deleterious vascular outcome is
they say hey here's a thing we observed
don't know why but sure is interesting
and they kind of kind of leave it at
that
I got you now the American Heart
Association they made a statement in
2018 and and I I can put the link to
that in the show notes as well but
basically they were talking about this
kind of this little cluster of papers
that came out with some of these
outcomes related to stroke and dementia
and they said in various cardiovascular
and metabolic outcomes they said taken
together some observational data
suggests that there is this association
between low calorie or non-caloric
sweetener jiz with you know diabetes
cardiovascular disease things of that
nature but again they noted reverse
causality really cannot be ruled out
there and in many cases those
confounding effects of prior obesity
seem to really be pushing some of these
effects in the observational literature
when I say pushing that's again
speculative one of the downsides of
observational data is we we can't really
say what's causative and that works both
ways you can't assert reverse causation
any more than you can assert you know
the typical causative relationship but
but the evidence does seem to be at
least compatible with the idea that
there's some serious reverse causation
going on so to the listener that brought
this question up to my attention thank
you for doing that I definitely should
have covered this aspect of the
literature the first time around
but for people who do consume artificial
sweeteners the good news is again with
these particular outcomes when you add
stroke and dementia to the risk again
there just doesn't seem to be a strong
case by which you it you would demonize
an artificial Swit sweetener or ascribe
any kind of deleterious effects to it
you know it's this EPI stuff is really
tricky because in many cases it's the
best evidence we can really hope to have
but there's a classic figure it's gone
or it's made the rounds I'll link to it
to an article that features it but it's
a graph and the title is everything we
eat both causes and prevents cancer and
so when you see these observational
outcomes with really big sample sizes
and and you see they're really low
p-values we're we're kind of naturally
wired to take those at face value and
say oh god I got to stop consuming
whatever that was but the figure is just
hilarious so I mean for it for milk for
example if you if you look at individual
studies there are studies showing that
it protects against cancer and the
relative risk is down it looks like
around 0.3 maybe even a little bit lower
but at the same time there are study
shows means it reduces cancer risk by
like 70% correct yeah so either a 70%
reduction in cancer risk or an over 500
percent increase in cancer risk with a
relative risk over five so if you look
at these individual studies within these
you know epidemiological outcomes it can
really lead you astray
you really have to first of all get a
better sense of the broader body of
literature but more importantly with
these types of outcomes you also have to
be able to figure out like is there
actually a plausible mechanism at play
here so like like Greg the first thing
you thought of was oh it's supposed to
do that how yeah and and what you'll
find in a lot of these really surprising
outcomes where you're like oh my god why
was that associated usually you can make
a really strong case for
reverse causation or some kind of
confounding variable really dictating
the results and in many cases you'll say
okay well there's a really good case for
reverse causation in this case obesity
really driving those effects what is the
case for an actual direct causative link
between artificial sweeteners and the
outcome in many cases you come up short
and in those cases you're like well I'm
gonna be inclined to think reverse
causation is at play until I see
stronger evidence to indicate otherwise
yeah I think like I think when it comes
to to epi stuff in general I think a
good knee jerk reaction to have is well
show me the mechanism because I think
that oftentimes people can on the flip
side maybe be a little bit too
dismissive of epidemiological research
because it has had huge misses in the
past but like you said oftentimes epi
stuff is the best quality evidence we
have and realistically the best quality
of evidence we can hope to have because
I mean you know it's not like they're
gonna recruit a sample of folks who are
like 50 years old until one of the
groups like hey you got a drink three
cokes every day for the next 20 years
and tell the other group like hey you
have to drink three diet cokes every day
for the next 20 years like that studies
just never going to happen so like yeah
I mean oftentimes it is the best
evidence you can hope to get and so like
if you want to ascribe if you want to
attempt to ascribe causation to
epidemiological research the first step
toward being able to even attempt to do
that is trying to find a plausible
mechanism and you can absolutely
accumulate enough evidence that you can
start to become very very confident so
for example that's that's like the whole
deal with tobacco and the link to lung
cancer it was it was resisted for so
long because that wasn't something where
you could do an RCT on it
especially because if you're proposing
oh I think smoking cigarettes gives
people lung cancer
hey IRB is it ethical to test that
they're gonna say [ __ ] no like if you
think this intervention is going to give
30% of your sample lung cancer we're not
going to sign off on that but a
combination of a lot of mechanistic work
to see you know how the the various
chemicals could have carcinogenic
effects combined with the
epidemiological research was eventually
able to build an incredibly strong case
but if it is just one epidemiological
study and there's no really strong
plausible mechanism to explain the
findings it is worth being very very
skeptical of absolutely and I'm you know
far from a you know general epi hater so
I've actually done some work that you
would consider epidemiology I guess you
know big survey based observational data
with a sample of you know a couple
thousand people and so as long as you
understand the limitations of it and you
contextualize the findings and interpret
the findings accordingly I mean this is
a really useful research tool so I agree
i have seen people online who the minute
they see any kind of observational
research design it's like a knee-jerk
reaction they just type whelp
correlation ain't causation and they
just completely ignore it and and that
is really not what you want to do what
you want to do is look at it and say how
strong is the correlation how repeatable
is this in other similar studies and
what mechanisms might be at play
okay I'm gonna complain for maybe like
two minutes okay okay one of the things
that pisses me off to no end what you
just mentioned is [ __ ] when people
just mindlessly spout stuff like
correlation doesn't equal causation
because the thing is that is the the
more technically correct expression
would be correlation doesn't necessarily
imply causation but whatever like even
if you're using the more technically
correct version
there are some people who just throw
that out in a wall I am very smart type
way while simultaneously making
themselves look like complete dumbasses
because the person they're responding to
wasn't making a [ __ ] causal claim in
the first place like someone will just
get on Facebook or Twitter or something
to me like oh this is interesting this
study found an association between those
two variables nowhere in the text of the
[ __ ] study does anyone try to imply
causation nowhere in the post where it
was being shared does anyone tried to
imply causation and then like people
just jump in and they're like oh but
guess what correlation doesn't mean
causation shut the [ __ ] up everybody
knows that like that is not a that is
not a goddamn novel insight if someone
is trying to draw causal inferences from
mere correlations then sure hit them
with the classic hit him with the
correlation doesn't necessarily imply
causation but if people aren't trying to
draw causal inferences from correlations
just don't do it it's so [ __ ]
annoying yeah what I like to do one of
the things I like to do when people just
use that phrase way too much as I'll say
you know a t-test a comparison the two
groups mathematically is literally
equivalent as just saying the outcome of
interest was correlated with group
assignment and you'll get the exact same
p-value it's mathematically entirely
equivalent and usually that keeps people
busy thinking about their entire
worldview and then they stop saying it
as much all right so you have a research
review about sleep restriction correct
uh yeah kind of that is at minimum my
jumping-off point so there's there was a
study it'll be about a week old by the
time they're listening to this but it is
currently hot off the presses the title
of it is the effect of sleep restriction
with or without high intensity interval
exercise on Maya fibrillar protein
synthesis in healthy young men by saner
at all
and so this this was a pretty
straightforward study it used a
five-night intervention and there were
three groups so one of the groups slept
normally they didn't have their sleep
manipulated slept about eight hours per
night there was a sleep restriction
group where every night for the five
nights they had them sleep just four
hours per night which would be quite
unpleasant that is you know fairly
serious sleep restriction and then a
sleep restriction plus exercise group
where for the five nights they also
still slept four hours per night but
they also did some high-intensity
interval exercise during the
intervention period and they used they
used a deuterium based method to look at
basically long-term muscle protein
synthesis so basically instead of like
looking at how quickly like a
phenylalanine tracer is taken up
immediately post exercise or something
like that you look to see how much of
like the the labeled water is
incorporated into muscle proteins over
time so you can basically get an idea of
what muscle protein synthesis looked
like over a matter of days weeks
possibly even months if you know if you
have enough deuterium for it
versus just like a super acute muscle
protein synthesis study so they were
looking at muscle protein synthesis
rates over this five night intervention
and what they found is that the sleep
restriction without exercise group had a
small but fairly notable decrease or I
can't necessarily say decrease but they
had a meaningfully lower amount of
muscle protein synthesis compared to the
other two groups so the fractional
synthetic rate in percent per day was
about 1.2 for plus or minus 0.2 one
percent so about one point to four
percent the non sleep restricted group
it was about one
half percent and the sleep restriction
plus exercise group was about 1.6
percent the the non sleep restricted
group and the sleep restriction plus
exercise group had significantly higher
rates of muscle protein synthesis than
the just sleep restriction group but the
sleep restriction plus exercise group
and the normal sleep group were similar
to each other in terms of muscle protein
fractional synthetic rate and so just a
quick quick little note about this study
I would have really really liked to have
seen a fourth group which was normal
sleep plus exercise to see if that would
have still been pretty similar to the
other two could two conditions or if
that would have had higher rates yet of
muscle protein synthesis so I think that
would have been pretty informative but
at minimum this tells us that one rates
of muscle protein synthesis are likely
depressed if you're not sleeping enough
hard to know if this would apply to say
like sleeping six hours per night versus
four but if you are considerably
sleep-deprived you are probably at a
lower jazz a basal rate of muscle
protein synthesis but if you continue
exercising and keep in mind they weren't
doing like bodybuilding style training
here was just high-intensity interval
training that was enough to maintain
muscle protein synthesis rates similar
to normal sleep so that in and of itself
I think is kind of cool but I kind of
wanted to use this as a jumping-off
point to make a point that I think we've
talked about on the podcast before but
if we did it was probably at minimum six
months and probably close to a year ago
which is that I think I think when it
comes to like muscle protein synthesis
and just building muscle in general
people overlook just how important
exercise is and so in I don't know I
could have a completely misconstrued
view on this but I occasionally see
people asking so I've come across this
question probably four or five times in
the past month of people saying like hey
so like I'm about to take some time off
of training like I'm going on vacation
or I'm about to have to travel for a job
in the place I'm going doesn't have a
gym so if I eat enough protein how like
will that help me keep a building muscle
or like you know is that going if I eat
a ton of protein will that help me
maintain all of the muscle I built
through training and stuff like that and
so like in general like higher protein
intakes are generally better and I don't
think anyone's contesting that but the
degree to which essentially anything
matters compared to exercise exposing
your muscles to work intention
everything else it with the exception of
steroids just absolutely pales in
comparison so I think this study is a
decent example of this very very serious
sleep deprivation you know if you add
some exercise on top of that still
probably not ideal for long-term
training outcomes but was at least
capable of putting folks on a relatively
even playing ground to folks who were
actually sleeping enough the study that
I think is is the most interesting to
kind of elucidate this is one of the
people who's on my thesis committee dr.
dr. Eric Hanson he did a study or he was
part of a study that was looking at the
effects of androgen deprivation therapy
on muscle protein synthesis so ADT
it probably has some other clinical uses
but I know it's primarily used in in men
with prostate cancer because essentially
like testosterone and DHT accelerate
tumor growth in people who have prostate
cancer so one of the primary treatments
is you take drugs that essentially
suppress your testosterone levels to
zero so not just like kind of
garden-variety low tea but like just
straight-up no testosterone whatsoever
and so they found that I mean they
didn't find that this is something
that's super well known ATT depresses
just basal rates of muscle protein
synthesis if you're a dude and you have
no testosterone in your body your
muscles don't kind of hum along in
synthesized protein at the same rate
which shouldn't be too shocking to
anyone but they found that if you take
min on androgen deprivation therapy and
have them perform resistance training
and compare them to a group of of men
with normal testosterone levels who
undergo resistance training muscle
protein synthesis that is actually
virtually identical I think I think it
was still like nominally lower in the
people who had who are on ADT but you
know it was like a pretty big baseline
difference just like resting muscle
protein synthesis and then post-workout
you know the ATT group it was like 95
percent the fractional synthetic rate of
men with normal testosterone so like
dude exercise of resistance training
it's it's super clutch like it it does
like all of the other stuff we talked
about absolutely matters but like just
getting in the gym and doing something
some sort of physical exercise and
ideally weight training has such a
larger effect on muscle metabolism and
like long-term effects on hypertrophy is
so much greater than than literally
anything else another so
I mentioned people who are like
obsessing about protein intake versus
asking like oh hey I'm traveling for
work what's like some bodyweight
training I can do when I'm gonna be out
of the gym like like that that's the
sort of question you should be asking
because like eating eating protein when
you're not training will probably help
you maintain more muscle mass but is
still trying to find some way to do some
sort of training is going to have an
enormous Lee larger effect and so yeah I
think one of the other like illuminating
things to look at is if you look at
protein research and you look at studies
comparing higher versus lower protein
intakes something like two thirds of
them don't find a statistically
significant effect if you pull them all
together in a meta-analysis you do find
like surprise surprise eating more
protein does help people either like
maintain more muscle when they're aging
or build more muscle when they're
undergoing resistance training but the
effect is relatively modest and then you
compare that to studies that compare an
on exercising control group to a group
of people undergoing resistance training
mmm I mean like it's at that point it's
not even worth comparing like obviously
you get tremendously better muscle
growth hypertrophy outcomes with
resistance training than not resistance
training so yeah I mean like a lot of
[ __ ] matters but just simply doing
something physical is going to have a
way way bigger impact than then
literally anything else you can do and
so I'm sure that I'm preaching to the
choir here I doubt that there are many
people who listen to our podcasts who
are like hmm I'm trying to pick up tips
from these guys about how to exercise
less and still get decent results so
yeah I'm sure you you guys are already
sold on this but uh I don't know I think
it's just worth keeping in mind
of all of the things that matter or
don't matter I think it's worth kind of
I think it's worth having a rough
hierarchy in mind of what matters more
than other things and to what degree do
things matter more or less than other
things that you could do and at the
foundation of that pyramid like the most
important thing bar none is how much
exercise you're doing and the type of
exercise you're doing everything else I
don't want to say is just the cherry on
top because it can have actual
meaningful effects but exercises is a
million percent in the driver seat I'm
just gonna say it I I'm I think this is
a personal attack because you know that
I've been out of town for the last like
seven days you know that I haven't been
training and I feel like it's not a
coincidence that this is the day of all
days that you get on your soapbox and
say hey when you're traveling make sure
you do something why are you so worried
about protein I did not know you hadn't
been training what do you think I was
what do you think I was doing I don't
know you could do like [ __ ] push-ups
in your hotel room
I was in the middle of nowhere in
Vermont there were no gyms around and I
hate body weight exercise there was no
floor there was a floor there were
several floors interesting yeah okay so
you're clearly shaming me for not
training last week and that's fine but
I'm gonna get back into it and I'm gonna
be bigger and better than ever
okay so on to some q and A's right user
all right first one looks like it's for
me alright so a question here from the
Netherlands loves you
what's up with recent news about
antibacterial mouthwash having
deleterious effects on blood pressure
via oral bacteria and nitrate nitrite
nitric oxide etc well throwing out my
Listerine result in reduced blood
pressure and more importantly sick pumps
yes I didn't know that there was recent
news about it but this is something that
has been kind of known in the nitrate
literature for for a few years now so
absolutely there's an effect here if
you're using like a really
strong antibacterial mouthwash it will
completely knock out any benefit that
you would hope to receive from a nitrate
supplement so when we consume nitrate
what happens is bacteria in our mouth
our oral cavity reduce that nitrate to
nitrite not all of it but some of it and
then what happens is you know we it goes
down into the stomach we absorb it into
the blood but there actually is kind of
an active cyclical loop by which nitrate
in the blood will get taken back up by
the salivary glands and we can do even
more conversion of some of that blood
nitrate down to nitrite and then back
through the GI tract and there's this
kind of cyclical loop but the really key
point here is without those bacteria in
the oral cavity that conversion from
nitrate to nitrite cannot happen and so
yeah if you're thinking oh I'm gonna go
get a really nice beetroot product or
some kind of nitrate product and get
some really nice pumps and you're using
a strong antibacterial mouthwash that's
killing all those bacteria you are not
going to get what you were hoping for
and so that's a really important
consideration
now the question about blood pressure
absolutely that there are some studies
looking at large groups of people and
they do find that users of you know
antibacterial mouthwash do tend to have
slightly higher blood pressure which is
fascinating now the actual magnitude of
that effect is very very small so you're
not going from you know great blood
pressure to hypertension because you
decided to use some mouthwash
however it is one of those things that
the statistically significant
relationship supports what we would
intuitively expect which is that that
conversion of whatever dietary nitrate
you're getting in to nitrite which is a
critical step if you're trying to make
nitric oxide from the nitrate you're
taking in you can't circumvent that step
if you don't have those oral bacteria
that steps not happening and that's why
we do see at these
the big like population-level users of
strong antibacterial mouthwashes tend to
have blood pressure that's like a couple
points higher so it's not a huge deal
but if you're trying to use some kind of
nitrate based supplement or if you're
eating more nitrate intentionally to try
to enhance your performance you are not
going to get those benefits if you're
using an antibacterial mouthwash
regularly so very important to keep in
mind and if you look at the methods of
any paper that does you know any kind of
beetroot or nitrate supplementation the
majority of them will we'll put in the
methods you know we told everybody don't
use any mouthwash during the study okay
Gregg we got question for you this one
is from max what is your stance on the
conjugate method for Raw lifters would
you recommend it in the long term and
how would you adjust it for raw lifters
if any adjustments are necessary yes so
there is both a very straightforward
answer to this question and a moderately
straightforward answer to this question
and it ultimately comes down to how one
defines the conjugate method so one so
the the conjugate method essentially
just means in a nutshell a form of
programming or periodization where your
training multiple physical qualities at
once so that's in that's an opposition
to something like classical linear
periodization where you know you might
only train for a hypertrophy and then
only train for strength and then only
train for power etc so like if that's
the definition you're using then
conjugated periodization is essentially
like I think it originated with like
Russian periodization folks Louis
Simmons popularized it in the West but
it is essentially synonymous with
concurrent periodization which is
literally the exact same concept
and yeah I mean you can you can do that
so like DUP would be an example of
concurrent periodization or conjugate
periodization so you know you're
training you have a session that's
focused on power you have a session
that's focused on strength you have a
session focused on hypertrophy all in
the same week you know lots of people
use a DUP type set up long term and
that's completely fine so if that's the
definition of conjugate you're using
where you know you're kind of going with
a textbook definition where it's
essentially synonymous with concurrent
periodization then yeah sure there's
there's nothing at all wrong with that
so then the second possible definition
you could be using is the conjugate
method basically just means everything
Louise Simmons ever said about power
lifting and I kind of think that's what
most people mean when they talk about
the conjugate method so let's talk about
west side for all lifters so I think
that I think that a lot of people have
unnecessarily just completely dismissed
west side and I'm I'm not necessarily
trying to like stand for Louise Simmons
or anything like that but uh I think I
mean I think we can still work that's
what got me into powerlifting in the
first place like I trained kind of
Orthodox west side did some did some
things that were probably somewhat
ill-advised but like I made gains I got
stronger I found other things that
worked for me better down the line but I
mean it was still it was still good and
most of the people I trained with at
least at one point kind of in that time
early in my career we were all raw
lifters we were all doing kind of like
Orthodox West Side stuff we all had good
results see I mean like it works the
question is just like could one make it
work better for raw lifters
and you know are there other ways that
that may work just as well if not better
but so I'm just going to address that
first one basically how how would I
adopt or adapt kind of like classical
West Side programming for raw lifters so
I think the first thing that I would do
is Lois Simmons recommends box squats
kind of for all people in all
circumstances I don't really see much
utility from from box squats for raw
lifters it's not that it's necessarily a
bad exercise but one of the big benefits
of box squats if you're in a quit power
lifter is you can kind of like mimic to
some degree the stopping power of stiff
squat suit and stiff briefs you
obviously don't have that if you're
squatting Brawl so I think you're going
to get much much better carryover from
either just drastically reducing the box
squats you do or just not doing box
squats so that's probably where I would
start next thing that I would probably
change but not eliminate completely if I
went back and did Westside again is I
actually quite liked using accommodating
resistance and I own a set of chains but
someone else currently has that set in
their possession and I need to go get
those back I'm not crazy about bands and
I think that's more of a personal thing
but I love chains I think they're
absolutely fantastic one they're just
cool and two I don't know I think I
think they're kind of a happy medium of
letting you feel heavier weight then
maybe you can move through a full range
of motion unloading some of the joints a
little bit at long ranges of motion
where possibly they're creaky or at
least mine are while it's still feeling
very very comparable to just straight
weight whereas that's the thing I think
I lose with bands but I do like
accommodating resistance injury in
general and especially chains
but I think one of the bigger things I
would recommend is if you do use
accommodating resistance for like
Westside style dynamic effort work I'd
recommend going not quite as crazy with
the accommodating resistance so ah man I
forget Louie's recommendations right off
the top of my head for like what
percentage of total resistance should
come from chains or bands but it was
something reasonably high I think he
generally recommended like forty or
fifty percent of the total resistance
coming from chains or bands and I would
say for a row lifter just because the
strength curve isn't that extreme so you
know with with equipped lifting like the
gear is giving you more help at the
bottom than it is at the top and so you
have like a pretty extreme wonky
strength curve and like a strength curve
for a raw bench press or a raw squat
isn't perfectly flat by any means but
it's certainly a lot flatter than
equipped so I think like I don't
necessarily think you're gonna get
better results from using an
accommodating resistance but I don't
think it's going to hurt your results
and I think that for raw lifting it
would make sense for maybe something
closer to like twenty twenty-five
percent of the total resistance coming
from chains and bands rather than like
forty fifty percent next thing I would
probably address would be lift selection
so you know not just a shoeing box
squats but the the lifts you cycle
through for max everyday you know I
don't think you should be doing a bunch
of a bunch of high board press or
anything like that
Louie absolutely loves or at least at
the time that I was following Westside
absolutely loved good mornings kind of
thing you should just stick to deadlifts
and squats and variations thereof so ya
wouldn't really worry about lockout work
too much
certainly you know if you do board press
sticked like one and to board like that
I don't think raw lifters really need to
worry about messing around with 3 & 4
WordPress I think you're gonna get more
utility out of squat variations and
deadlift variations and just doing a
crap ton of good mornings and I will say
Louie has been an exceptional
powerlifting coach and he's produced a
ton of huge squatters and huge benchers
and like there have been some big dead
lifters who have come through Westside
but they by and large haven't attained
quite as much success in the deadlift as
they have the other two lifts do with
that what you will I do think and I'm
just going about going off of what I
remember from Westside like 2012 and
prior I don't know maybe Louie has his
guys dead lifting all the time now at
least back then they weren't dead
lifting much but yeah dead lifts they're
good dead lifts will probably carry over
to dead lifts a little bit better than
good mornings well and then the last
thing that I would address would be
accessory lifts selection so again back
when I was doing Westside stuff Louie
was all about you know trained posterior
chain all the time make sure you do your
make sure you do reverse Hyper's forty
seven times a week and for upper body
stuff make sure you're hammering the
triceps who cares about the pecs you
just do a [ __ ] ton of tricep work for
raw lifters you know you're using your
pecs a lot in the bench press for here
for your Westside accessories
you know triceps certainly keep training
them but don't neglect the chest as well
and for lower body stuff having a strong
posterior chain very cool very awesome
would highly recommend it but also quad
strength plays a bigger role in the raw
squat than it does the equip squat so
don't issue quad work in your
accessories as well but yeah the the
overall structure of like Westside style
conjugate periodization I think is solid
and can absolutely work but I wouldn't
necessarily pork this
that Louie developed for equipped
lifting one-to-one to raw lifting so
just kind of recap get rid of the box
squats go a little bit lighter on chain
weight and band tension like you can
still use it but you know probably
twenty twenty-five percent of the total
resistance for dynamic effort days just
use use lift selection for max effort
days that is more appropriate to raw
lifting so longer ranges of motion
deadlifts instead of a bunch of good
mornings I feel like that should be
pretty straightforward and then for
accessories you know still train the
triceps and posterior chain but don't
neglect the quads don't neglect the pecs
alright next question is by whoever and
it is for Eric so Eric whoever asks I
mix creatine night before any drawbacks
to this so I'm assuming this means they
basically mix their creatine leave it
and then they consume it the next get
the next day who's that what it sounds
like I think so yeah so there's a paper
by yogurt in 2011 and it talks a little
bit about the stability of creatine now
creatine is extremely stable when it's
stored in dry conditions at room
temperature
however creatine is not very stable
after it's mixed into a liquid solution
now not all liquids are the same in
terms of the rate of creatine breakdown
so the creatine that you put in a
solution is going to break down faster
if the pH is low or if the temperature
is high so like the worst thing you
could do is put it in a really hot
acidic beverage and then leave it for
several hours and consume it later so
ideally you'd want to mix your creatine
close to the time you take it but it's
not a huge deal so that they've got a
really nice figure in that paper by by
yogur and what they do is they they kind
of chart the amount of creatine
breakdown over several hours mixing the
creatine into the beverages of very
pH levels now over 72 hours if you've
got a your creatine mixed into a
beverage that's got a pH between 6.5 and
7.5 even 72 hours later you're still
gonna retain about 98% of that creatine
so that magnitude of creatine breakdown
as far as I'm concerned is essentially
negligible but if you're mixing it into
an acidic beverage you could see as much
as you know 20% of your creatine
breakdown over a 72 hour period what you
also notice when you look at these
different time courses is you know
regardless of the pH up to about 8 hours
the the relative amount of breakdown you
only see about 3 or 4 percent really
actually more like 2 or 3 percent of
breakdown in those first eight hours
after that the acidic beverages between
8 and 24 hours that's where you start to
see a little bit more of the breakdown
occurring and then it just continues
from there so you know within 8 hours
it's really not a big deal once you get
beyond that you probably want to start
thinking about at what temperature are
you storing it and what is the acidity
of the beverage the best-case scenario
is just mix it right before you have it
but you know anything within that 8 12
24 hour window should generally be fine
as long as it's not in a super acidic
beverage now there is a lot of times
whenever people ask about timing of
creatine I just throw this in anyway you
know there's the timing of when you mix
it relative to when you drink it another
common question that I might as well
answer while we're here is what's the
best time of day to take creatine I get
asked that a lot there are a couple a
couple studies indicating that it might
be slightly slightly slightly more
beneficial to consume it after a workout
compared to any other time of day like
before the workout or just totally
separated from the workout generally
speaking though the timing of creatine
is is really not a super essential thing
to worry about
if you were you know really focused on
getting
that last half of a percent out of your
creatine supplementation you might
consider moving it to the immediate
post-workout period but whether you're
taking it in the morning the night
pre-workout post-workout creatine tends
to absorb it in the muscles very very
well and the timing of your creatine
relative to the workout really not that
big of a deal okay that does it for the
Q&A segment of today's episode the next
segment is actually a brand new segment
we are calling it on the rise and and in
this upcoming segment what we're doing
is basically highlighting a someone in
the fitness space who's making really
good content but maybe doesn't have a
particularly huge following or deserves
to have a bigger following than they
have you know basically someone making
good content that we think if you're a
listener of our podcast you might have
an interest in checking them out and and
Gregg if people want to nominate someone
for this how do they go about doing that
so I set up a like Google form and you
can find that at tiny dot CC slash
creators that is again tiny dot CC slash
creators awesome so for the first ever
on the rise segment who is on the rise
Greg okay before I reveal that first I
need to give a big meaty disclaimer
which I will probably give before the
segment every single time we've recorded
absolutely um in all circumstances if we
if we promote someone on this segment
that is not a carte blanche that is not
a saying we agree with everything this
person has ever said so please please
don't message us and say hey four months
ago
this person said one thing that
disagrees with this thing that you said
two years ago you want to fight about it
no I absolutely don't you know not
necessarily say saying we agree with
everything that they've ever said about
anything Fitness related just that we
checked out some of their
10 seem to be generally good or we found
something that they were talking about
that was quite good not a blank check
number 2 if and for this one we're
starting with I would be very
disappointed if it turns out that any of
the people we end up promoting turn out
one day to be utter and complete
[ __ ] we accept no responsibility
for that we it's not like we have a
massive interview thorough vetting
process so yeah disclaimer get that out
of the way yeah we're not making
appointments to the Supreme Court here
this is just saying hey here's somebody
doing good stuff and yeah if we were to
make a segment where we did just write
that blank check and say I support
everything this person has ever done or
will ever do that list that probably be
like a 2 episode segment before we
retire it and probably by the time we're
all done in the fitness world that we'd
probably regret at least one of them
correct so anyway with that disclaimer
out of the way I actually for our first
time ever doing this segment I would
like to start with a little bit of
nepotism and talk about my friend Meghan
Calloway
so I met Meghan this past year at the
Evolve Canadian strength symposium up in
beautiful Edmonton Canada so Meghan's
great we hung out the whole weekend if
you are interested at all in pull-ups
she is the person to check out she does
talk about other things but pull-ups are
her bread and butter she has thought
about and obsessed over pull-ups more
than anyone probably ever probably more
than is healthy but because she is so
hyper specialized in that one thing if
you want to know anything about pull-ups
she's the person to ask if you want to
get better at pull-ups she is the person
to go to she has a
I guess ebook guide called the ultimate
pull-up program it's really good I've
read it the last time I was on sale I
actually shared it on my Instagram story
there were a fair amount of people in
our audience who got it and then like
made a point of messaging me back a
couple weeks later saying like hey I
picked up ultimate pull-up program it
was super good I enjoyed it a lot
so that was that was good to hear but
yeah Megan's great she's a fun person to
be around
absolutely fantastic nose pull-ups
inside and out so if you'd like to check
out Megan and her stuff Instagram is by
far the platform that she is the most
active on she is at Megan Callaway which
is Emmy gh8 in CA ll a w a y and we will
put that in the show notes but yeah
she's great and like I said if if
pull-ups are your jam her work is the
work to check out yeah I've met Megan as
well she's really cool she does good
work and now her responsibilities you
know being the inaugural person
showcased in the segment is to never say
anything wrong for the rest of her
career because Greg and I do not want to
hear about it so Megan the pressure is
on don't make any mistakes ever again
sound good
perfect well that implies she ever made
a mistake that that that's not I don't
necessarily know that but starting now
no mistakes okay to close out the
episode to play us out today
people have been clamoring they keep
saying Eric we want more of your cooking
tips and they're sick of Greg taking it
up and so everybody relax you're gonna
get more of Eric's cooking tips at the
end but Greg saw it in the outline he
got really upset that I was giving
cooking tips so he wanted to give one so
just kind of tune this out when you hear
my voice come back on you'll know the
real cooking tips are ready but I'm
gonna let Greg go first yeah so
so this is more just like a general
recommendation then you know
specifically recommending like a dish or
anything like that but uh I think
mushrooms are pretty slept on mushrooms
are fantastic and I think like when I
see people talking about diet stuff
online the the the great fungi of the
world seem to be sorely left out people
talk about you know what uh what meat
they're eating what protein sources
they're using what they're using for
starches their vegetables and when when
I see people make lists of like hey
here's like the vegetables and stuff
that you should eat when you're cutting
mushrooms aren't a vegetable so maybe
they're not putting it on the list as a
technicality but mushrooms are
definitely something you should keep in
mind so they again are not vegetables
they're not plants they are fungi but
they have kind of a similar
macronutrient profile and some of the
general benefits that one would get from
eating plants so they're low in calories
they're high in fiber
they're very satiating and this is
coming from me I don't love vegetables
but I love mushrooms and you know if
you're someone who is in a similar boat
maybe it's worth giving mushrooms more
of a shot so mushrooms are very very
cool not only because they're good for
you and high in fiber and I think
personally quite delicious if you are
say maybe not an incredibly confident
home cook mushrooms are quite possibly
the easiest food ever to cook so if
you're cooking say vegetables if you
undercook them like maybe there's still
a little crunchy ER than you want or
whatever but they're generally fine then
they're kind of perfect for a very brief
moment and then you overcook them and
they're just mushy and kind of sad and
not good you can very clearly over an
under cook betcha
meat especially is the same way so you
can under cook meat it's still for all
you get sick you die
it's no fun and you can also absolutely
overcook meat it dries out the texture
[ __ ] doesn't taste as good anymore
mushrooms because of their their protein
structure and god I should have looked
this up I believe it's called chitin
just the way that that traps moisture
and helps maintain the structure of the
mushroom better than say cellulose dozen
plants it becomes incredibly difficult
to mess up cooking mushrooms so like you
can under cook them and they'll still
just kind of have the the mouthfeel over
all mushrooms which I personally don't
find super pleasant but if you do want
to make cooked mushrooms it's so easy
you have so much leeway where you know
you cook them it seems like most of the
waters come out you try one
it seems mostly done maybe they could go
a little bit more if you just like leave
the pan on this on this stove and forget
about them or say like you're boiling
mushrooms and you leave them in the
water for a little bit longer and let's
say you forget about it for 30 minutes
like a completely unconscionable amount
of time when you come back they'll still
be just fine mushrooms
whereas if that was any other food it
would be completely ruined by that point
unless it was like a meat dish that you
were trying to braise but like for the
most part there's a there's a reasonably
small acceptable range of like cooking
temperatures and times mushrooms just
completely blow that out of the water
very very hard to mess up cooking
mushrooms the other cool thing about
mushrooms at least for me is they so I
love meat I love it so much and I feel a
little I feel a non-negligible amount of
guilt about how much meat I eat but it's
not just for the protein like I just
really really love meat one of the cool
things at least for me for
mushrooms is they helped scratch a
similar itch because unlike say
vegetables I can't think right off the
top of my head of any vegetable that
gives me the same sort of bite that meat
does and the bite you get from a cooked
mushroom is not identical to meat but
it's it has a somewhat similar to some
nests that you're not necessarily going
to get from cooked vegetables and it's
also quite savory so mushrooms most
varieties of mushrooms are high in free
glutamates which is what produces the
umami since the umami taste or the
savory taste same thing that makes like
stuff flavored with msg tastes delicious
and also there's high levels of free
glutamate in meats so it it scratches a
similar itch that way as well and man
you can make some really really really
good mushrooms that within your diet can
function essentially the same way you
would use vegetables super simply and
there they're gonna scratch that savory
itch if that's you know something you
want in in non meat products so you can
sear the [ __ ] out of mushrooms it'll
develop like it'll it'll caramelize I
believe it undergoes a my yard reaction
like I think that there's enough like
tightness protein that that you can
actually get some my art browning as
well
just throw some salt and pepper on it
possibly even some soy sauce go super
well with it very salty very savory
insane depth of flavor you can eat it on
its own you can use it as like a garnish
for other dishes or you can throw it in
soups ton of flavor
very good for you very easy to cook and
and just gives you a different flavor
flavor sensation then you're gonna get
from from vegetables that you would
otherwise be eating for you know with a
similar slot in your diet so yeah you
can do a lot of stuff with mushrooms I
just want to remind you guys the
mushroom
exist because I like I said think they
are super slept on and that most people
should probably be eating more mushrooms
okay if you tuned out during Greg's
jealousy fueled mushroom propaganda it's
time to listen up because it's time for
Eric's cooking tips now if you've
listened to my cooking tips in the past
you know that my whole thing is I like
cooking things that are inexpensive
extremely easy and require literally no
time or effort and so that's exactly
what you're gonna get here I
whenever I start trying to kind of get a
little bit leaner whenever I start a cut
or a mini cut and I decide I want to
lose some body fat one of the things
I've always done is really ramped up the
amount of spicy food I eat it was just
kind of something that I naturally found
whenever I had a super spicy meal I
tended to be very satiated after the
meal I didn't tend to gravitate towards
snacking in the post meal period and
honestly if you've been keeping tabs on
the capsaicin oil it heurich err in
recent months there's just nothing to
dislike about capsaicinoids right now
you look at the literature there's some
evidence that capsaicin and but when I
say capsaicinoids by the way we're
talking about the capsaicin related
compounds that make hot peppers hot and
it's what gives them their their spicy
flavor and that that heat sensation so
capsaicinoids there's there's literature
indicating that you know capsaicin
or cap c8 which is a capsaicinoids cap
c8 supplements have been shown to
increase reps to fatigue there's
research showing a multiple
capsaicinoids to have a thermogenic
effect to potentially have a in effect
by which they reduce hunger or desire to
eat after a meal and so across the board
there's there's plenty of reasons to
love spicy food and to love
capsaicinoids and most importantly spicy
food tastes awesome so what I'm gonna
give you here is basically the meal that
I eat for essentially every meal
currently and so what it is it's my
spicy chicken recipe here's what you do
you make your chicken in the crock-pot
that's gonna last you the week or you
know at least several
days put all your chicken in the
crock-pot you put it in with a jar of
salsa and then I usually just fill it up
with water to the point where the
chicken is submerged in the crock pot
you cook that you're good to go for you
know the next several days and when
you're actually gonna have the meal what
you do is you take out a bowl you put in
frozen chopped pepper and onion mix so
like bell peppers and some onion chopped
up buy it frozen at the grocery it's
already pre raw pre-washed pre-chopped
ready to go I also put in frozen rice -
cauliflower as well so that's my
vegetable mix put it in the microwave
for a couple minutes just get it to like
cool temperature you don't need to you
don't need it to be hot like you're
about to eat it you just want to
basically get it to a similar
temperature as the chicken that's been
in your refrigerator for a day or two
then you put the chicken in you mix it
all together you get that you know you
get it heated up in the microwave to the
temperature you want to eat it at then
you pull that out and here's where the
magic happens what you're gonna do
you're gonna put on some salt some black
pepper some cayenne pepper and some
chili pepper okay and then on top of
that you're gonna put some sriracha hot
sauce now this meal has incredibly good
macros you could get as lean as you
would ever possibly want to get eating
meals like this it's basically a bunch
of fiber some micronutrients and some
chicken tastes awesome
I will admit the way that I put the
spices on in the sauce it's more of a
challenge than a meal I break a sweat
because I go really heavy with the
spices but it's just an awesome easy
meal super quick to make super cheap I
mean this is a foundational meal that I
usually eat whenever I start cutting
super cheap super easy and if you're
like me and you hate spending time
cooking it is awesome Greg what do you
think of that meal sounds ok I'll make
it for you sometime you've you've made
me a couple meals in the past I feel
like I owe you one
got some really good sauteed mushrooms
in the fridge okay
you want to try some I definitely do I
haven't eaten in like many many hours so
I'm gonna go try these mushrooms and see
if I can verify all the propaganda that
Greg shared a few minutes ago
that does it for this episode as always
thank you for listening we'll have
another one up in two weeks thanks for
listening to the stronger by science
podcast now Greg and I are not experts
in medicine or health or really anything
else for that matter so before you make
any changes to your diet and exercise
habits make sure you check with a doctor
or another healthcare professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it
visit stronger by science com to check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you